how to find the developer I got a great
question from our youtube visitors
love you guys Robel who wrote in this a
very inspirational video I need some
help I've got an idea I've done the
research on it but the problem I have is
finding a developer who could execute my
product this is a great question and for
anybody who's in technology hey we need
developers to make things happen your
three options are find the business
partner who's a developer hire a local
developer or get somebody to outsource
it to ok I'm going to go through the
pros and cons of each and you can decide
what's best for you the cheapest way is
to go and outsource it right you find
somebody who's no different country has
lower cost of living the prices are
lower this is great when you have
project-based work when you don't need
to see them face to face where you can
be really specific on what you need to
have accomplished and it's great one of
my favourite websites to use for it is
oDesk I've hired a lot of great people
on oDesk for lots of different types of
projects including Christina who edits
all these videos hey Christina so it
could be a great tool for you what I
think you really need to decide is are
you going to be a technology company or
not okay if you're gonna be a technology
company then you need somebody on your
team it's not just having somebody local
face-to-face that you can meet with but
you need somebody who's investing their
heart and soul into this business to
make it better a buddy of mine runs a
web-based business is a technology based
company and he's had some growth and
success but he's always been limited
because he doesn't have a dedicated tech
person on his team he doesn't have a CTO
a chief technology officer you need
somebody who is dedicated to your
business not just paid a salary but is
living and breathing your company just
like you are if you're gonna be a
technology company so that's the big
decision if you are you are you just
launching a product that you need some
build on there maybe some support on
that you can outsource or have somebody
local that you meet with face to face
art or do you need somebody who is
committed to this because you're really
building a business around products and
technology that's a really important
decision okay if you're going to
outsource
America
oh just calm go check it out you could
post a job you can interview people you
know you put it through trial jobs and
see which one you work best with if
you're gonna do a local hire you know
you can put up the job posting you can
meet people face-to-face you could do
some group interviews I like doing group
interviews first and then going to
individual interviews and you can find
the programming you need if you're
looking for a business partner it
becomes trickier because you need
somebody who believes in the same thing
that you do right you have someone who
has the same values wants to build the
same thing as you do the best way to do
it is you have to get out and start
talking to people you've got to talk to
your current network your friends your
family people you know let them know
what you're looking for then other kind
of projects you're working on and also
go out and start hanging out at events
go to meetups go to industry events
places where programmers would likely be
and start telling them about what you're
doing and find somebody you can click
with write a business partnership is
like getting married you know you're
spending probably more time with them
during the week than you are with the
person you marry so you know you need to
have some way that you can really really
really get along with who you know it's
it's not only good in the good times
we're good in the bad times as well so
you don't just rush into it
start working on something small see if
you work together well and expand from
there but your real decision is do you
need to build a technology company do
you want somebody who's really going to
be part of your team and help you build
this thing out we can just offshore this
or delegate it out to somebody to help
you build you figure that out you're
close to the beam on your path and
that's how you find the right developer
believe those are your watching you like
the video thumbs up below
let me know what you think ask me a
question underneath leave a comment
below I'll make a video response and if
you want to see more videos like this
subscribe to my channel by clicking on
my face thank you so much I'll see you
soon